those things answer each other and so
the thing that i'm working with right
now i'm not necessarily investing in one
particular coin or the other
um i'm i'm in the process of creating a
uh i don't know if you know what an etf
is but it's
like a basket of stocks and so if you
take for example the s p
500 or the nasdaq it's the number they
show every day on cnbc
uh that number is basically taking 500
different stocks and adding it all
together with a special formula and
that's how they say oh the stock
market's up and it's
bad or it's down and it's diversified so
you've got a little tech it's got a
little bit of healthcare's got a little
bit of everything
and so if you wanted to be an investor
that you really don't get to learn
anything you say i want to buy the s p
500 because it has 500 different
companies and they're all over the place
and i don't have to ever think about
this again and so you can do that you go
and you buy a share
it's called spy that's the ticker symbol
for it and that share
basically behind the scenes they go out
and they buy everything for you and it
makes everything really easy
what i'm creating right now are these
same products
for real stocks in the crypto world uh
so this means
if you want to buy or
and i'm putting a community aspect of if
you want to buy
some gold because you think gold is
going to go up you're worried about
inflation you like tesla because you
like the cars or you like elon musk
you like samsung right because if you
have the phone
uh but they're in korea mind you they're
not they don't trade in the us
uh and you want some bitcoin because
people are talking about it that also
doesn't trade on the stock exchange
uh and you want to buy whatever some
other real estate
right if you want to do all those things
it's like how do i even start i don't
feel like learning these things
we're creating this coin this this type
of coin this token that goes out and
buys all that stuff for you
and so you just buy this thing once and
if you write about your
about what you wanted to do then you
make money or lose money or whatever
uh and it's it's kind of got a wall
street bets kind of feel to it and it's
called the wall street bets dap
um uh and and so it involves all the
coins so i know that's probably not the
answer you were looking for
but through the community i'm going to
let them tell me what to invest in if
the community says
we want to ethereum and bitcoin in
whatever dogecoin
and uh i think i can't even name half
the coins in there and we want to buy
apple then they can do that package it
together into this little
stock that i can buy and then i'll just
buy that stock and that's how i'll get
involved
and they'll make it easy to do that so
that i don't have to learn about all
these crypto wallet things that i have
to put into my safe and blah blah blah
you know i can do that if i want but
i want to be able to just click three
times and just like with robin hood just
click that up arrow and then call it a
day so this is like
an etf for everything for stocks for
gold for crypto
and it's using look it's because it's
undeniable that the crypto technology
kicks ass like it's cool right uh and
and they've proven that it's cool
because it's
survived for so long they haven't been
able to break it yet and it's
and it's decentralized so you know that
just means that they can't turn it off
the government gets mad they can't just
ask amazon to shut off the servers for
it
uh so it's resilient right so it lives
everywhere it lives in this ominous
cloud
and it's decentralized so that it's in
the hands literally of the community and
and then but you put all the mechanisms
in place and that's exactly what you get
you get an etf
that the community decides on probably
and they could have 10 atf's they could
have like the yolo i'm going to go crazy
all or nothing bet
you can have the warren buffett etf
which is like the boring whatever slow
and steady dividend collecting whatever
and then you can put everything into
this etf absolutely everything
and use the blockchain technology to
make it secure just like everyone loves
it
and behind the scenes we're buying up
all these underlying things so it's
actually
it's called collateralized that means
that this little thing that you that you
own
represents something else just like when
a lot of people own gold but they don't
physically have the bullions in their
basement they have little certificates
that says well this is redeemable for
one bar of gold
well these little certificates are
redeemable for a little gold a little
stock a little bit of crypto a little
bit of everything else so how do people
know that this is like
all this stuff is legit are these tokens
that they're buying that this etf you're
talking about like how do you know that
this [ __ ] is actually redeemable and
what makes it legit one of the things i
most like about kryptos how paranoid
they are well it's annoying sometimes
right
but but it makes me comforted because so
many people are paranoid
and it's all audited and it's all
auditable and it's all open source
and it's all uber transparent it's even
more transparent like
i don't know why i keep bringing up
robin hood but when you buy the stocks
on robin hood all these things happen
behind the scene it goes to the payment
for
a full company and that goes to the
exchange that goes to the clearinghouse
and they have to put up the
settlement dates in the collateral all
these things happen after you click your
little arrow
right uh that that are complicated in
the crypto world it's all
out there on the internet you can see
exactly where your coin is and then
how that money and you could trace the
path all the way to the exchange and see
that what
what uh what you said is actually real
so it's a combination between
trying to reach the the layman's like
myself say hey just trust me this is
actually what happens
right because some people just don't
have time uh but then
then you have the technical side of
people like no no i don't trust you i
want to see it for myself well it's all
out there go read it and if you
understand how to do
programming stuff you'll you'll you'll
see for yourself so is this available
right now or is it something you're
that you're developing we launched so
it's it's a
it's kind of two stages the first thing
that we do is we launch these tokens
and so people buy these tokens and that
that happened last week
they can find it on wsb wsbdap.com
uh and that's all the instructions once
you buy the tokens
right you're technically like a
shareholder in this wall street bets
organization or fund or whatever
and then we start creating these etps
and in this summer we're going to start
launching the first
uh rounds of these gtps the community is
going to come together
they're going to basically upvote just
the way they're going to harness the
power of the community to say okay guys
what do you think if we put
put it all into bitcoin and that's it
we're not going to put anything else or
if we're going to do some really
sophisticated thing and
this is why i think i'm right then
everyone kind of votes and you vote with
your shares with these tokens that
you're purchasing so if i have 100
tokens
i have 100 votes and then and then
everyone collectively does it
the the interesting thing about that is
there's studies that have come out that
have
analyzed the subreddit wall street bets
for their stock picks and they've
i mean this is like a graduate level
study with math and graphs and all these
things 50 pages long
and they concluded that wall street bets
is better at picking stocks than the
general stock market that they they
actually beat the market they're
they're an effective hedge fund or a
heck
effective investment uh bank and that's
promising and that makes sense because
people collectively tend to be really
smart you have some dumb people that
just follow
you have some really smart people with
really good ideas those ideas get
more visibility and so if we take a big
community
and all these guys that are buying these
tokens they all create these and you can
create one etf that's like i said
earlier the yolo you can create
just crypto you can create the whatever
uh and then people
whether or not they're involved with
with this this organization with this
fund
anyone can buy it so if you say look i
don't want to get into crypto i don't
really care to buy your wsb
token you could just wait for these
products to come out this summer
and you can see hey there's three of
them there's the high risk low risk and
medium risk you're like i just want the
middle risk right and so you can just
buy that directly and not have to worry
about it
that's pretty [ __ ] incredible man
yeah did you so you started this are you
just like
advising them or how involved are you in
this i i i came out as an advisor
because i don't know anything about
i didn't even know this was possible
right so the i've been people people
have been reaching out to me
for years wanting to to do crypto stuff
and also wanting to do etf stuff on the
on the stock edge
let's make a watch for about ctf uh and
i've said no to all of them
and it's because they're uninteresting
and i don't really care very much for
for what they're going to contribute
back to society this one came across
and at first i said no i straight up
said no to them i'm like i don't do
crypto stuff they're like no no hear me
out
this this is not your typical crypto and
then i got really freaking excited
because
because you're right this is not your
typical crypto we don't even care about
the price of the coin per se a lot of
people buy dogecoin because they want it
to go up they want to make a lot of
money
uh to be frank to me i don't care as
much what the price of the coin is as
much as how
many people are getting involved because
i want a lot of people to vote on these
etfs
to to to revolutionize it like i said
earlier these worlds are merging
wall street and crypto emerging there's
the potential is massive it's huge i
mean think about the fact that i cannot
buy samsung right now because i can't
uh because i'm in mexico or the us and
and people in india can't buy tesla but
for the same reason it like it you can
just oh
and i can't buy uh or if i was a crypto
guy i can't buy a
mortgage-backed security right but now
you can with one click of a single
button making it so easy
uh to marry those two worlds where
they're already going anyways so
so they brought me on basically is kind
of a bridge they're all crypto people
i'm only wall street
they're like you're the perfect dude you
know just enough about crypto
right you're not going to get sucked
into this world so you can understand
how these hash functions work you can
just
continue to speak the language that you
speak uh and you can help
help attract crypto people towards
buying stocks
right or mixing them and you can buy you
can get normal stock equities or
whatever people
to get into crypto as well wow this is
definitely the first time this has ever
been done right
yeah to investing like this there's
nothing that's ever been done like this
the proof of concept is there like i
said the the the
there's an exchange that allows you to
buy just a share of tesla so they did it
with tesla
so it's done right once you prove that
you can do that then it's doable
uh you there are challenges that need to
be overcome but you can't
get right into these mortgage-backed
securities it takes
you know there's a set of steps that we
need to get to before we get there but
right off the starting gate we can start
with crypto and we can start with a lot
of these stocks
and very shortly after that because etfs
are part of stocks
through etfs you can get all sorts of
other stuff and then uh
as those challenges get fired up but
nobody's done it collectively like this
with the vision of marrying
crypto with wall street uh with the
with the further vision of democrat
democratizing uh finance for just about
anywhere
anyone anywhere
you